[Musique]
au Liban il est connu comme le loup
blanc son nom Michel
efteriades c'est le patron du Musicall
l'un des haut lieux de la vie nocturne à
Beyrouth il est aussi producteur
businessman agitateur politique un
personnage mystérieux mais aussi très
influent rencontre avec le maître des
soirées libanaises eniablé il a surtout
une histoire comme souvent les hommes
les hommes caractérisés comme cela ils
ont une vie derrière eux al le cas de
Michel c'est que il a eu une vie il a
toujours été résistant il a il a même
combattu il était pas toujours du bon
côté c'estd celui qui gagnait mais il
était résistant chaque fois qu'on me
parle du Liban je demande des nouvelles
de ce phénomène
etterades pour savoir ce qu' devient
j'ai fait donc cet éloge du militant du
militant de base qu'il a été du musicien
de
l'écrivain l'homme amateur des BeauxArts
aussi de peinture mais je crois aussi
que c'est plus que cela et que
certainement le dans le Liban qui vient
il devrait occuper une place plus
grande je pense que
michelfteriad fait partie de ces
personnes qui si elle n'existait pas il
faudrait les inventer je dirais de lui
que c'est véritablement un cosmopolite
au sens le plus noble du terme un
internationaliste qui en a eu assez de
ces division de
l'humanité hello thinkerview je réponds
à vos questions depuis mon lounge
leutopianao en plein cœur de Beyrou la
capitale du
Liban on ne peut plus parler du du poids
de la parole diplomatique française au
Moyen-Orient elle n'existe plus c'est la
parole américaine c'est ils sont devenus
des
porte-paroles de la parole américaine
c'est devenu de de tout petits
pions des poissons pilotes qui qui
navigu avec le grand requin dans
l'espare de recueillir des des miettes
c'est vraiment pathétique la France
avait un grand rôle dans cette région du
monde
la diplomatie française a
eu son heure de gloire c'était une
référence dans la diplomatie mondiale
c'est devenu maintenant
des comme disait mon ami Jacques vergess
la [__] des
Américains ce qui s'est passé en Syrie
euh
récemment a été une grande
humiliation pour les États-Unis et ses
alliés euh je sais pas comment ils vont
pouvoir justifier euh toute cette
excitation toutous ces préparatifs pour
partir en guerre et puis du jour au
lendemain après que le l'ours russe est
montré ses dents ils sont se sont
soudain à Sagi il c'est devenu soudain
des des grandis des euh des gens qui qui
qui qui ont qui parlent de dialogue qui
veulent une une solution pacifique pour
la crise en Syrie donc je sais pas
comment
euh comment être crédible après un tel
virement la France
la politique étrangère de la France est
une politique
mercenaire la France ne peut plus vivre
comme à l'époque de du colonialisme elle
n'a plus des colonies qui peuvent lui
permettre de vivre dans
l'opulence les Français devraient
travailler plus il devraient respecter
les investisseurs il devrait créer un
système qui respecte les ambitieux quand
on parle la longueur de journée de petit
petit petit en parlant du café de la
sortie du dîner de la tout la culture du
petit on peut
pas exiger du grand et vouloir vivre
comme des nababes
euh maintenant ils essaient le
néocolonialisme au lieu de partir
eux-mêmes en guerre ils envoient des des
armes
rouillées à des proxis à des mercenaires
qui font la la la guerre à leur place
dans l'espoir que c'est une fois ces
mercenaires au pouvoir ils vont pouvoir
rafeller des des contrats pour
reconstruire le pays pour exploiter les
ressources naturelles de de de ce pays
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait un peu avec la
Libye ils ont pensé que ce que ce
système qu'il peuvent faire best best
practice de ce de ce système et essayer
de de l'utiliser ailleurs mais euh la
Syrie n'est pas la Libye ce qui peut
être valable dans dans un pays où
l'armée
est n'est pas une vraie armée ne peut
pas être appliqué dans des pays qui ont
de vraies armées qui ont des des gens
qui ont qui qui qui sont plus qui
analysent mieux ce qui se passe et on
peut
people
people c'est-à-dire que il il il ils
peuvent le faire une deux fois mais la
troisème fois la 4ème fois ça devient un
peu difficile à faire à faire passer la
chose même si
euh si le clown Bernard Henri Levi euh
fait des des des poesses incroyables sur
des chaînes internationales pour
expliquer que Bachar alAssad est un
islamiste dangereux même s'il va faire
de grands discours sur les valeurs de sa
fille philosophie humaniste et sur il
est plus crédible il est il est
complètement grillé et c'est dommage que
que la France qui a de grands
philosophes encore aujourd'hui et qui a
eu des des des des philosophes qui ont
changé l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est dommage que qu'elle
accepte que quelqu'un comme Bernard
Henry Levi puisse encore passer sur des
chaînes internationales avec en dessous
French philosopher donc ça c'est une
honte pour l'histoire de la philosophie
française et pour la la culture
française en
général en général je suis
contre
l'impérialisme qui découle Dee des
superpissance la Russie en est une mais
quand je compare la situation actuelle à
la situation de
l'unipolarité américaine qu'on a vécu
les dernières 20 30 années je préfère
avoir une Russie forte avec un nouveau
tar avec quelqu'un qui a qui a qui a qui
s'est imposé sa volonté ça limite les
dégâts le pouvoir absolu corront
absolument la les États-Unis étaient
devenu très
arrogant parce que il savait que il
pouvait
partir là où ils veulent sans jamais
avoir de comptes à rendre qu'il pouvait
faire les erreurs qu'il qu'ils peuvent
faire sans être puni
et ça ça c'est très dangereux parce
que des millions de morts sont appelés
collateral damage donc pour eux c'est
des nom c'est de collateral damage c'est
c'est pas grand-chose mais pour nous qui
vivons dans cette région du monde c'est
nos famille c'est nos amis c'est des
vies entières qui sont qui sont broyé et
ils l'ont fait ils l'ont fait à
plusieurs reprises il voulait continuer
à le faire jusqu'à ce que la Russie et
Poutine viennent leur dire non Poutine
est un grand leader le monde ça fait
longtemps que le monde n'a pas connu de
de vrais grands leaders la France avait
eu une tradition de de chef d'État de
grande culture qui avait du charisme qui
avait du talent qui qui qui avait du
style mais maintenant c'est c'est c'est
vraiment des des médiocres là on a eu
deux deux médiocres pas on mais les
Français ont eu de je me sens un peu
français quelque part vu que ma culture
et mes lectures sont sont françaises
euh c'est triste c'est triste que la
France n'est pas son Poutine qui
pourrait redorer un peu le blason de de
la France c'est triste de de de voir un
chef d'État français qui sait pas
marcher sur un sur un tapis
et qu'une femme doit remettre dans dans
la bonne direction c'est triste de voir
un un un Chef français qui qui sememble
à rien qui qui est là qui n'a même pas
compris qu'il y avait un accord qui est
qui était en train d'être signé entre
les les Russes et les américains et qui
même quand les les Américains avaient
rappelé leur leur serber lui il était
toujours là à Boyer il était encore tout
excité c'est vraiment triste pour la
France et c'est par amour de la France
que je le dis
on peut pas parler d'une
perception unifiée dans la
région quand une décision russe est
applaudi par une partie de la population
moyen orientale il y a l'autre partie
qui l'a maudit et viceva euh il y a il y
a deux axes actuellement il y a un
axe russe chinois
iranien plusieurs parties de d'Amérique
latine et dans la région il y a des gens
qui adhèrent à cet axe il y a l'autre
axe où il y a les États-Unis Israël la
France des l'Angleterre des pays comme
ça donc il y a partout dans le monde il
y a un fort clivage entre ces deux ces
deux axes et leurs partisans
euh sous prétexte de
démocratie l'Occident est en train de
d'armer et de porter son son appui à des
hordes
barbares qui pratiquent le cannibalisme
qui
pratique
des des comportements médiévaux parfois
même encore bien plus plus ancien des
choses de la de la guerre du feu des
coupeurs de tête ses VI en
Syrie ils
appliquent ce que ils appellent la
chararia qui n'a rien à voir avec la
vraie chararia islamique c'est des
malades qui qui viennent du monde entier
pour
détruire une civilisation magnifique qui
a survécu à plein d'invasion et qui est
arrivé intact jusqu'à nous je parle de
de villages comme maloua ou l'araméen la
vraie langue du Christ et encore
parler et ces gens-là vont en quelques
mois détruire cet
héritage
soutenu par l'Occident sous prétexte de
e on nous parle
de démocratie on parle d'établir une
démocratie en Syrie alors que qu'ils
sont alliés de l'Arabie Saoudite du
Qatar de plein de de pays qui qui nont
rien à voir avec la démocratie la Syrie
c'était pas Byzance la Syrie c'est
pas c'est pas la la la
Suède la série de Assad mais au moins
c'est un pays où il y avait les droits
de la femme où les minorités pouvaient
vivre bien les minorités religieuses
sexuelles et autres où il y avait une
classe moyenne où on pouvait parler un
temps soit peu de politique on n pas le
droit d'insulter le président mais il y
a plein de pays et de démocratie et de
grands pays qui ont une grande culture
de tolérance et de libre de parole libre
qui ne tolère pas il n'accepte pas
d'insulter les chefs d'État donc c'était
pas vraiment la Syrie c'était pas un
despotisme tel qu'on essaie de le de le
dépindre maintenant et même si ça avait
été le cas on ne peut pas sous prétexte
de faire tomber un régime qui n'est pas
très
démocratique faire alliance avec des des
des sauvages avec des des gens tels
qu'on voit maintenant en Syrie
je suis contre une intervention contre
toutes les
interventions je pense que un pays qui
un peuple qui ne peut pas lui-même se
libérer un peuple qui ne peut pas
lui-même faire sa
révolution ne mérite pas d'être
aidé un peuple qui qui sait pas se
respecter le une file se mettre en en
ligne quand on va en en Syrie dans plein
de pays arabes on voit que ok ils se
mettent ils se mettent en ligne mais
c'est elle est elle est horizontale la
ligne au lieu d'être verticale
c'est-à-dire que il il faut commencer
par éduquer les peuples avant de leur
donner le droit au vote ça fait des
années que je dis que si demain il y a
des élections dans le monde arabe c'est
les islamistes qui vont prendre le
pouvoir il faut commencer par aider les
peuples à travers la culture la culture
est primordiale ce qui prépare la
culture c'est euh c'est des philosophes
c'est des écrivain c'est
euh c'est c'est des des intellectuels
qui peuvent créer chez chez les peuples
une conscience qui peuvent installer une
conscience qui prépare les révolutions
dans des
révolutions dans dans dans cette partie
du monde ceux qui
ont ceux qui vont voter ils vont écouter
la parole du du
Cher et même dans dans même pour les
chrétiens du de notre région c'est aussi
c'est la parole du curé or le le curé et
les chaires n'ont jamais mené à très
loin c'est les philosophes c'est c'est
des gens qui qui sont qui ont une plus
grande ouverture d'esprit pr qui peuvent
mener les peuples vers des démocraties à
la à la scandinave ou à l'européenne ou
à des démocraties où il y a le respect
de l'individu il y a le respect de de
de de la divers de la
diversité de l'autre mais si c'est la
parole du Cher et la parole du curé
bonjour La la
nouvelle la nouvelle Constitution
il y a plus à mon avis il y a plus
d'intervention directe occidentale en
Syrie et même à l'époque où je suis très
amis avec des gens des Nations Unies des
gens très haut placés et j'étais un
débat où il voulait savoir s'il fallait
évacuer au Liban ou non parce qu'il il y
avait toutes ces préparatifs de de
guerre américaine et j'insistais et j'ai
parié avec eux qu'il y aura pas de
frappe américaine
personne personne ne peut supporter ça
aucun chef occidental ne peut prendre le
risque maintenant de le faire de
déclencher une troisème guerre
mondiale je connais bien les Russes j'ai
j'ai vécu un peu là-bas et euh je sais
que quand un président russe dit niet ça
veut dire niet c'est pas on verra et
peut-être et donc ils peuvent pas le
faire les conséquences auraient été
désastreuses un peu on a vu déjà le
résultat en Irak en Syrie ça a été
encore pire et pas que la Syrie quand je
dis la Syrie ça ça ça aurait été le
Liban aussi et ça aurait embrasé toute
toute la région donc je pense que on a
évité le pire j'espère que en Syrie ça
va pas être une guerre de
longue durée ce qu'on appelle low
intensity conflict qui peut durer très
longtemps c'est pas une vraie vraie
guerre mais c'est c'est des bandes de
Mad Max qui se déplacent et qui sèent la
terreur qui qui brûlent des villages qui
qui violent qui coupent des Têt qui qui
font des délires et ils sont très
difficiles à à éliminer parce parce que
ils continueent à venir ils viennent de
de tout le monde arabo
mususulman et
c'est c'est un réservoir illimité ça
peut faire l'affaire de plusieurs pays
d'envoyer d'envoyer au chez le
charcutier tout tout ce stock de
potentiel terroriste mais ça coûte très
très cher à à la Syrie et au Liban aussi
à tous les pays pays de la
région j'espère que la Russie va pouvoir
imposer qu'elle a assez de cartes pour
pouvoir faire Press et arrêter ce délire
en Syrie je pense que Assad ne peut pas
revenir au à
l'état à la à la légitimité qu'il avait
avant avant les événements en Syrie il
va devoir faire des concessions c'est le
cas dans toutes les négociations dans
toutes les négociations les deux parties
sont appeléses à faire des des petites
concessions et je pense que en faisant
de petites concessions et en trouvant
une sorte de de scénario de nouveaux
pactes ils peuvent reconstruire euh la
Syrie euh il y a des gens à exclure ceux
qui qui qui ont détruit leur pays et qui
ont été des mercenaires à la solde de de
des monarchies du péttrar ou bien des
puissances
étrangères ne n'ont pas leur place dans
dans dans le nouveau pays euh ça va
mettre du temps mais je suis plutôt
optimiste
le flux des réfugiés syriens au Liban
est une vraie catastrophe pour le Liban
c'est-à-dire que une population de 3
millions 3 millions et demi de de
Libanais ne peut pas
accueillir 2 millions de réfugiés c'est
un tout petit pays c'est à peine un
département
français et tout à coup il y a 2
millions de réfugé démunis qui
débarquent dans ce département c'est
inconcevable c'est une catastrophe
qu'aucun autre pays n'aurait pu
assimiler il y a ce côté miracle
libanais cette force résiliance des
Libanais cette capacité à absorber les
chocs mais il faut pas exagérer il faut
que le monde entier surtout que ceux
qui qui se considèrent comme les amis du
peuple syrien et ceux qui veulent le
bien de la Syrie se penchent sur ce
problème et viennent en aide à ses
réfugiés à travers le
Liban parce que c'est nous qui sommes en
train de payer avec notre
économie avec notre bien-être avec on a
déjà assez payé on a eu 15 ans de guerre
civile la Syrie avait pris part dans
cette guerre civile contre les Libanais
donc quand ils ont quand ça se passe
bien bien pour eux c'est l'armée
syrienne qui envahit le Liban et quand
ils ont des problèmes c'est les réfugiés
syriens qui viennent nous envahir donc
le discours peut paraître un peu
nationaliste il
peut déranger les viergesarouchées du
des bons sentiments et de l'humanitaire
et de ce qu'il faut faire de ce qu'il
faut pas
faire mais je suis en train d'être
réaliste
euh j'aime bien mon frère mais s'il
vient avec toute sa famille dans dans ma
maison et s'il veut dormir dans mon lit
et s'il veut me me me bousiller ma vie
je lui dis non il y a des
limites un invité un réfugié se doit
d'être un peu
plus discret un peu moins
envahissant c'est pas la peine de
devenir avec les deux trois voitures de
la famille c'est pas la peine de de
rouler parce qu'on a des emboutillages
monstre on est un pays de service on n
pas de de campagne avec des des paysans
qui sont en train de la cultiver qui qui
aide notre économie on n'a pas une
grande industrie on est basé sur les
services on peut plus avoir un meeting
on peut plus envoyer un papier assigner
d'un endroit à l'autre on on peut plus
rien faire le moindre trajet qui qui
prenait 2 3 minutes prend maintenant 1
heure donc c'est vraiment une situation
alarmante et le problème c'est que
chaque fois que j'en parle c'est lev de
bouclier et c'est
[Musique]
insulte euh j'ai de très bonnes
relations avec l'armée libanaise
euh dans ce lieu même chaque semaine je
rencontre des dizaines d'officiers
euh
euh je pense que
l'espoir du Liban passe par l'armée
libanaise que l'armée libanaise peut
vraiment faire un changement pour le
Liban que dans un pays aussi pourri où
il y a autant de corruption où il y a
autant de
communautés où il y a plus de de repèr
euh l'armée peut jouer un grand rôle euh
j'ai lancé une campagne de soutien à
l'armée libanaise j'ai demandé que
l'armée libanaise prenne le pouvoir
euh je suis pas c'est pas par amour de
de de l'armée en général c'est pas
dogmatique comme approche c'est réaliste
c'est c'est un peu aussi égoïste parce
que je connais
euh mon intérêt et l'intérêt des
Libanais l'armée libanaise est la seule
qui peut garantir
la la survie du
Liban avec tous les conflits qui sont
autour du Liban c'est un petit pays qui
peut être facilement contrôlé qu'on peut
diriger comme une forteresse ça on peut
appeler ça un coup d'État mais il y a
une une forme de coup d'état qui est la
plus acceptée par tout le monde qui est
le coup d'État gardien c'est quand des
officiers qui prennent le pouvoir non
pas par amour du pouvoir ou pour leur
propre intérêt mais qui veulent protéger
ce pays qui veulent être les
gardiens de de cet héritage de de ce que
nos parents nous ont laissé pour le
passer aux générations futures peut-être
pas les générations mais dans dans 10
ans c'est-à-dire protéger le pays
travailler sur les institutions préparer
une nouvelle
génération de de gens à travers une
nouvelle culture une nouvelle approche
imposer un livre commun
d'histoire calmer les les le clerger le
clerger musulmans chrétiens enfin tout
toute forme de clergé limiter l'action
des des des religieux et
préparer un nouveau pays ça prendra le
temps qu'il faut et l'armée donnera de
nouveau le pays aux gens il faut aussi
calmer les médias parce que la liberté
d'expression c'est c'est bien mais ça
donne pas le droit à à dire n'importe
quoi il y a il y a des limites or les
Libanais et plein de de pays arabe
pensent que la liberté d'expression
c'est le droit à l'insulte c'est le
droit au proséitisme à l'incitation
raciale à l'incitation religieuse or non
l'armée doit prendre le pouvoir l'armée
doit pouvoir tout contrôler si on veut
que le Liban existe toujours
le nourrissant est un projet culturel
social politique
philosophique et autres c'est un projet
qui qui offre des solutions à plein de
problèmes compensés sans
solution des solutions
faciles c'est une idée qui
qui est bien sûr qui peut s'apparenter à
l'utopie qui est une utopie actuellement
mais je pense que tout progrès à travers
l'histoire de l'humanité a commencé par
être une utopie et les grands les grands
pas de l'humanité c'était la réalisation
de ces utopies euh ça
devient de plus en plus facile
maintenant de communiquer un nouveau
projets le temps du noristan est
vraiment venu il y a plein de gens qui
sont
dégoûté par les
politiciens par la manière dont le monde
est est dirigé et qui pense que on peut
maintenant rêver et travailler pour la
réalisation d'un projet comme le
nauristan donc ça peut avoir plusieurs
nom mais j'ai choisi ce nom parce qu'il
a un côté amusant un côté
et je pense que c'est pas mal de de
présenter une idée qui est très sérieuse
qui est béton mais avec un emballage
avec une approche un peu plus légère
c'est beaucoup mieux que de de faire ce
que font les autres politiciens
c'est-à-dire servir de la merde mais
dans un packaging très sérieux donc vaut
mieux attirer les jeunes
ne pas faire un truc complètement
hermétique exposer d'une manière simple
et non pas simpliste d'une manière
simple des idées complexes des idées
sérieuses des idées qui découlent de
beaucoup de d'expériences et de
philosophie plutôt que de faire ce que
font d'autres politiciens c'estàd je
vois parfois des discours de politiciens
où il
parlent il présent très bien ils savent
ils savent très bien par parler ils ont
appris euh le le langage le body
language avec des des spécialistes et
ils sont très bien habillés mais ils
disent n'importe quoi c'estàdire quand
on analyse quand on fait une une saisie
de de de ce qu'ils ont dit et qu'on lit
le contenu de ce qu'ils ont dit ça veut
vraiment rien dire et ce truc dans les
débats présidentiels où c'est c'est ça
devient ridicule parce que c'est un
concours de qui a la meilleure mémoire
2.34 % des gens pense que et l'ut dit
non c'est 2.36 c'est mais on s'en fout
de tout ça ça c'est des détails qui
n'ont aucun sens parce que maintenant je
vais sur mon ordinateur je tape sur
google je googlise euh n'importe quelle
statistique je trouve tout j'ai pas
besoin d'un perroquet qui vienent me le
répéter à la à à la télévision j'ai pas
besoin de lire quelqu'un qui a qui a qui
a qui a une bonne mémoire ou quelqu'un
qui sait pas j'ai besoin de gens qui
apportent de solutions or tous ces
gens-là tous ces grands chefs et c'est
c'est de de partis européens et ses
chefs d'État n'apporte rien mais
vraiment rien et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une sorte de de nos future chez les chez
les jeunes chez la jeunesse européenne
ils sont des abusés ils ont 20 ans et
ils sont là à
[Musique]
penser le pourcentage je sais plus trop
quoi qu'ils auront à la retraite dans
dans 40 ans ils sont là à à à faire des
manifes pour des trucs mesquins mais
c'est pas ça qui va changer le monde
c'est pas ça qui va changer la vie des
gens il faut que les gens réalisent
qu'ils peuvent exiger un grand
changement le la campagne de Obama
c'était changement mais c'était rien
c'est des changements minimes c'est
c'est blancbonnet et Bonet blanc c'est
c'est c'est exactement la même politique
qu'il continue à faire mais sous des
slogans qui sont plus intelligents parce
que il est plus intelligent que le
cowboy qu'il y avait avant lui c'est
difficile d'être plus con que George W
Bush
donc c'est pas parce qu'il est un peu
plus intelligent qu'on devrait
s'extasier ou que les Américains doivent
se contenter d'un tel changement c'est
pas parce qu'il est un peu plus basané
que que le Yang qui qui avait avant lui
que on doit dire que c'est c'est la
victoire
de du du du du rêve de Martin Luther
King c'était pas ça dont parlait Martin
Luther King c'est pas de prendre un un
noir de mettre à là il est même pas noir
américain c'est c'est il un métis
afro-américain qui est qui est qui est
devenu président céit pas ça la victoire
des des Noirs quand on voit dans les
villes américaines maintenant on peut
toujours voir la misère que vivent les
la la population noire les descendants
des esclaves quand on quand on voit le
nombre de milliardaires et de
millionnaires blancs qu'il y a et le
nombre de milliardaire noir on voit la
différence qu'il y a et qui continue
c'est pas ça qui qui a changé donc il
faut exiger un
changement un vrai changement ce qu'on a
changé c'est ce que les Américains ont
changé et ce qui passe ce qui se passe
très souvent dans les changements de
chef d'État ou dans dans quand on passe
d'un parti à l'autre actuellement c'est
qu'on change seulement l'écran or les
virus parce que ce qu'on voit nous dans
d'un ordinateur c'est l'écran le virus
il est pas dans l'écran d'un ordinateur
quand on garde le disque dur quand on
garde le même environnement et qu'on
change l'écran on n'a rien fait il faut
un changement
radical je peux pas vivre je peux pas
envisager ma vie sans avoir un combat
noble euh vivre pour manger boire
baiser c'est pas une vie pour moi c'est
pas ok c'est important les plaisirs dans
la vie c'est important mais je dois
avoir une mission noble je dois avoir un
grand projet pour continuer à me battre
pour continuer à
apprécier pour continuer à apprécier euh
euh d'être sur cette terre donc euh j'ai
besoin d'un projet comme le nooristant
même si sa réalisation ne va je vais pas
voir la réalisation du projet mais au
moins j'ai le plaisir de de me dire
chaque fois que je suis un peu déprimé
chaque fois que je suis agressé par des
gens verbalement ou que je reçois des
des insultes de de mes haters que je me
sens menacé de dire ça vaut la peine je
suis en train de faire quelque chose de
mettre un train sur sur les rails et ce
train peut mener
l'humanité vers quelque chose de beau
vers c'est lendemain qui chanteent vers
des des des un monde meilleur et je suis
convaincu de de ce projet c'est pas une
vision que j'ai eu c'est pas un archange
qui est venu me visiter la nuit c'est
pas des voix que j'ai entendu c'est basé
sur une expérience personnelle une lutte
qui a commencé il y a 30 ans quand
j'avais 15 ans euh c'est des souffrances
la souffrance de perdre des amis de voir
des des des des amis tomber devant soi
c'est euh des années d'exil
c'est c'est la somme de de tout ça qui
m'a
permis de
penser la philosophie et le système du
du noistan je sais que ça va apporter
des des des des un grand bienfait à
toute l'humanité et avec la
globalisation maintenant on ne peut plus
parler de bien-être d'une partie de
l'humanité et pas de l'autre parce que
ça va générer desjaloux le voyage est
très facile l'Internet est là euh faire
des bombes et et donc s'il y a pas une
répartition des richesses s'il y a pas
une répartition du bonheur du bien-être
il y aura les pauvres qui vont venir un
jour rendre visite aux riches quand
l'argent ne va pas vers les pauvres
c'est les pauvres qui vont vers l'argent
un
voisinage
qui les quartiers
défavorisés s'ils ont faim ils sortent
et ils viennent dans les bons quartiers
pour casser la porte et ouvrir le
réfrigérateur et ça c'est à l'échelle
planétaire maintenant avant ce les
crèvent la fin ne savaient pas comment
vivre comment vivait comment vivent les
autres mais maintenant dans la dernière
des dernières favell dans le dernier des
derniers quartier populaire d'un d'un
pays arabe ils ont des satellites ils
voirent ce que les autres à quoi les
autres ont accès et ce que eux ils nont
pas il y aura toujours
un des riches et des pauvres mais ce
sera pas dû à à la naissance c'est pas
comme un un loto une un avir quand on
est maintenant en Suisse même si on est
idiot et paresseux on sait qu'on va
vivre mieux qu'un génie qui estit dans
dans quelques pays africains ou dans
dans dans des pays
défavorisés j'ai un message pour les
français et non pas pour le gouvernement
français je pense que c'est inutile
de de parler à des gens qui savent bien
que qui font de mauvaises choses mais
ils sont
aveuglés par le gain par les intérêts
financier donc ça sert à rien avec ces
gens-là il faut pas faut même pas
dialoguer ces gens-là il faut les les
punir les forcer à changer de politique
parce que on débat avec des gens qui ont
une idéologie différentes avec des gens
qui qui sont dans dans dans leur tort
parce que ils ils n'ont pas compris des
choses mais quelqu'un qui sait avec un
mafieux qui sait que ce qu'il fait est
mauvais c'est pas la peine de lui dire
non il faut pas faire ça il le sait déjà
mais c'est c'est peine perdu pour les
Français je vais leur dire de ne pas
être de ne pas se perdre dans les
détails et de ne pas sacrifier
l'ensemble pour le détail donc tous leur
débats et les tous ces clivages qui
n'ont plus aucun sens de droite et de
gauche parce que maintenant quand je
vois un je suis pas je suis pas de très
près la politique française mais
maintenant quand je vois parler un
politicien français je sais vraiment pas
je sais vraiment plus s'il est de droite
et de gauche et pourtant on continue à
coller ses étiquettes je vois parfois
maintenant des discours des gens de
l'extrême droite qui s'apparentent
vraiment mais on peut penser que c'est
des cocos des communistes je vois des
communistes c'est l'extrême droite c'est
donc il faut plus penser avec ces termes
il faut refonder la la la politique
française il faut refonder la politique
européenne il faut refonder la politique
mondiale la France a une place à occuper
dans dans le panorama mondial la culture
française est une des plus grandes
cultur du monde la Renaissance française
le siècle des Lumières la le rayonnement
de la France ne doit pas cesser la
France doit revenir à ce qui a fait sa
grandeur à ce qui a fait que la culture
française a inspiré plein de révolution
dans le monde ce qui a fait que cette
culture a toujours été celle des
révolutionnaires celle des gens qui qui
veulent faire évoluer des
sociétés laïques la laïcité est un
concept qui est très important et ça la
France a une place
de choix dans la promotion de la laïcité
cela doit être fait à travers la culture
la vraie culture pas pas pas celle des
des Bernard Henri Levi et
d'autres d'autres clown qui qui qui sont
les chouchou des médias parce que pour
plein de raisons
donc c'est c'est c'est
vraiment je suis vraiment triste quand
je vois ce qui se
passe je je j'espère je crois
en en la force du peuple
français qui
a qui a fait une des plus belles
révolutions et qui a euh qui a aussi
fait d'autres révolution culturelle qui
a quand quand quand je vois l'esprit qui
avait les écrits qui avaiit les les
graffiti de Mai 68 quand je vois la la
solidarité que la que la France a su
montrer pour des des
pour des causes comme la révolution
cubaine ou bien comme
a au Chili le prier le vrai 11 septembre
euh je me dis que ça peut pas s'évaporer
c'est pas aussi loin que
ça je pense qu'il y a un problème aussi
dans dans le système éducatif en France
parce que maises mes enfants sont au
lycée français donc quand je les vois
rarement parce queil vent pas au Liban
et que je je vois ce ce qu'il leur
apprennent je me dis que c'est c'est
triste aussi que il y
a il y a des choses que
que les les pédagogues quand les
pédagogues font des des erreurs c'est
c'est des générations entières qui sont
sacrifié c'est il faut revenir un peu au
Bones c'est pas très progressiste ce que
je vais dire pour un quelqu'un qui l'a
toujours été mais il faut parfois il y a
de de bonnes vieilles méthodes qui sont
en train d'être perdu que beaucoup de
laxisme n'a jamais créé de de grandeur
que rien dans ce monde n'a été créé avec
des fénéants avec des gens qui n'ont pas
envie de se lever tôt qui n'ont pas
envie de de de se battre qui qui qui ne
voit pas grand
[Musique]
vive à la Révolution un
petit petite démonstration il faut pas
avoir recours aux armes c'est le dernier
recours c'est pas caca c'est pas c'est
pas quelque chose qu'il faut
faire on voit à Washington il y a ce
grand problème de la drogue et il y a
des des sociologueses des médecins
toutes sortes d'experts qui disent que
il il faut vraiment changer la loi et
surtout pour commencer légaliser le
Marijana mais c'est un sujet interdit à
Washington moi je suis le le le parfait
exemple je pense qu'il a il y a pas
d'autres très peu d'autres exemples de
de ce que que les Canadiens appellent
les procédures Bayons c'est-à-dire que
vous vous êtes bombardé de procès et
Infiné même si vous gagnez vous vous
vous vous perdez quoi parce que le temps
que vous passez à vous défendre le
temps le monde avance et puis il y il y
a un espèce de rouleau compresseur comme
ça les révélations sur laffire prisme
sont intéressantes à plus d'un titre
déjà parce qu'on a maintenant la preuve
irréfutable de cette surveillance et de
son caractère massif et généralisé
pendant 10 ans on a collecté des preuves
des témoignages